[Music]
good evening and welcome to sidetrack
your sci-fi tv a movie channel i wanted
to go live this evening to talk to you
about stargate that's a bit of a shock
there um but a plan that has been
concocted by
a few of my fellow youtubers that also
love the show as much as i do
on july 27th they want to organize a
twitter store
so that we will absolutely flood twitter
with the hashtag we want stargate now i
think this is a brilliant plan but the
reason why i'm coming to you today to
talk about it really quickly is because
i want to add a little bit to that plan
so
first of all i'm going to talk about why
i think a twitter store like this would
work um and to quickly just give you a
quick update on where we are with
stargate at the moment so
i'm always talking to the people i talk
to that working around amazon and mgm
they're saying the same thing they've
been saying for about three four weeks
now that um everything um at mgm is
being reviewed
um but the as actually a little bit
added on to that is that they are now
telling me that actually bond is the
priority james bond
is the main priority for amazon that
they want to get right because when
they've gone into um when amazon have
gone into mgm they were not happy about
um what happened and what that what
they're looking at now that isn't
actually important to us for a couple of
reasons
because it also gives us a hint on why i
think
this twitterstorm idea could actually
work and could actually be effective
because amazon like numbers they like
things like this they like metadata and
bond really actually does prove that
because i know for a fact
that um two to three months ago
they were looking at a complete reboot
of james bond they were looking at
having a new young james bond that
reneged on page was the front runner he
was also the bookies favorite
this is the young guy uh 1920. he's now
actually gonna going to do the saints
instead
but when amazon have gone in they've
said no we don't want this we what do
the people want and they looked at the
metadata and the metadata basically told
them that idris elba was going to be the
most popular person for
you know from the general public to have
as the next james bond
so now
just two or three days ago we found out
that
mgm studios and the production company
behind james bond have officially begun
talks with edger zelda to become the
next james bond now
whatever you think about that is
irrelevant the important point for us
from stargate fans
is that amazon forced mgm to change
their plans i mean to completely change
their plans because idris elba not only
is he a black guy which james bond isn't
but we'll ignore that he's also of a
certain age he is into his 50s
so the mgm plan of completely rebooting
james bond and beginning with a younger
james bond the the plan that i was told
was that we were going to see james bond
before double 07.
has been completely scrapped and they
have amazon have forced mgm to go in a
completely different direction
as is there right because amazon own mgm
now stargate can go a similar way it is
in review we don't know what the plan is
but what we do know is that amazon love
figures they love
hello there right you are going to be
somebody i'm going to mention in a
second
so
they love metadata
so
leo marievor or sebastian here um
actually messaged me on my previous
video and said get in touch he told me
all about the twitter storm plan and now
on july 27th at 1pm in la 4pm in new
york um 2200 hours at night um in france
or 9 o'clock here in london um this
storm will happen and the plan is that
everybody will send messages with
hashtag we want stargate
the plan being that it would flood
twitter with this and create lots and
lots of lovely metadata and you know a
story for something for amazon to sink
its teeth into and we know from james
bond that this would probably be
effective it could work
now to help with this
i've actually created a series of
t-shirts that are going to be for sale
on my um merchandise page that i will
not make any profit from it is simply
hashtag we want stargate and the sim
logo
please the link is in the description
what i would absolutely adore is for as
many of my subscribers as possible i'm
approaching 10 000 by the way when i
last looked i was only 20 away so if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit the bell notification and
subscribe because i would love to go
over 10 000 while i was live that would
be incredible
um
but yes i would love as many of my
subscribers as possible to buy the
t-shirt again i don't make any money off
it and send photos either into me or
even better when we do the twitter storm
you take a picture of yourself wearing
the t-shirt with the hashtag we want
stargate because
from what i'm told i don't not a big
thing of twitter i don't really
understand twitter particularly well but
what i'm told is actually that um to get
more
figures to get the numbers up actually
the hashtag alone isn't enough if you
connect an image to it or something else
then that actually drives and you get
you go higher up the trending list
because of that
so
apparently now i'm only three away
from 10 000 subscribers shelly thank you
so much that is very exciting let's see
if we can go uh um to ten thousand today
that would be incredible
so
let me
make thank you for one sharing it with
me and two for letting me know that this
was such a good idea and and you know
we'll get on board with it and let's see
if we can make it work
because like i said if this is something
that can work and should work
amazon
they're really the perfect company to
manipulate in a way
um obviously by the way if you want to
go to startrek.com you can also buy
merchandise i will make money off cert
there are a few of the products there as
well
but there are
this is the company that
they do care about demographics and they
do care about the numbers
and they're not going to do anything
without doing research
look at stargate 4 of star trek 4 sorry
it's about to come out one of the things
one is about to go into pre-production
one of the things that the director said
to me was they looked at the numbers he
didn't say to me so he said in a um
report you know to a reporter but he
said they looked at the numbers and they
said it's really obvious that people
really want star trek so that is again
more evidence that the production
company
didn't go can we make a great movie they
went what do the numbers say
and this is what matters and amazon are
suckers for that so
thank you vert smart very smart i'm
gonna go with very smart thank you very
much sir then i am probably also
inviting you to come on to a video and
with me at some point that sebastian
that would be amazing i'd love to talk
to you
um and also go and find um
medieva i can't say i'm sorry i'm not
french but um go and find his channel as
well um it's a really big it's probably
the biggest um stargate pushing and
sci-fi channel in france and one of the
largest in europe please go and
subscribe to him as well he's doing
loads of work on this and um i know he
told me he's already contacted joseph
mosey and he's putting loads and loads
of work into contact as many different
youtube channels and those already
contacted podcast and they've responded
to get as many people on this as humanly
possible so really let's let's do
something right uh let's have a look at
some of the messages uh michael hi matt
high amazon needs something the streamer
catalog has been thinned and they almost
down to a few hit shows they made
themselves
for me it was always really clear
that amazon are going to make stargate
it's it's a hundred percent
it's very clear to me that um looking at
brad wright actually speaking to brad
right once or twice that um he has no
clue what amazon are going to do
from what i'm told again from the people
that i speak to they don't know what
they're going to do
there was a plan in place there was a
100 definite plan in place what they
were going to do they were going to make
brad wright's um pilot they were going
to tweak it but that was what was going
to get made they've done early
provisional art they've done lots of
projects and all this stuff too to get
concept of what the show would look like
it was all done
they'd considered all the scripts they
decided to go with brad's
this was all right up until amazon
bought the company and they had those
big meetings in early april as soon as
that happened amazon threw water on all
those fires and they basically went to
oh i said basically again
it's a woman coke
and they told amazon and they told mgm
that right all of these projects are
going into review and we're going to
look at everything and obviously they
then came out with a statement saying
this is all done covered because
everything is going to be down to cover
it
and let me just have a quick look there
we will be here this moment thank you
very much so what i am going to do on
the 27th of july
i am going to be here in my
we want stargate
um
we want stargate
t-shirt doing a live show
um sebastian is going to be on he's
doing exactly the same thing we're going
to be sharing as many images as you can
send me um i will be obviously
going through twitter at the time and
having
a live look at what's going on on
twitter as we're doing it
um
and we're just going to make as much
noise as humanly possible the reason why
we're going to make as much noise as
humanly possible and i am sneakily just
have a look at my subscriber list
that's our mine's a little bit behind
i'm showing that i still need another
[Music]
to get to 20 000. but let's see um
tweet right now just to think just stuff
your fan fiction cartoon there there
that's amazing please do that andy i
have
the best conversations with andy and
he's one of those subscribers that does
not just agree with everything i say
which is which is what i want and he
will argue and he will tell me i'm wrong
more than happily
um but he always has respect and we
always have really really interesting
conversations and to be honest you learn
i i think you get so much more from a
debate in a conversation a respectful
debate conversation
michael screevo isn't that a good thing
isn't reviewing as they've made more to
put the franchise yep review review
review they're reviewing everything
apparently at the moment it's it's it's
an absolute nightmare
so what was i talking about sorry
so yeah
that's where we're at at the moment i'll
see you guys obviously you can actually
go to sidetrack.com and i should buy
this t-shirt as well which you can get
um
with i can never figure out it's left or
right when i'm looking in the mirror
sg-1 sga and sgu you can pick your team
go and buy a t-shirt cups whatever and
there's all sorts on there so please
gonna look but what i really want you to
do is go and buy the hashtag we want
stargate i want you to wear it on july
27th i want you to be on the live show i
want to be talking about it i want you
to be sending pictures to me i want to
go on the facebook page and put pictures
on there um but then i want you at nine
o'clock on the 27th to tweet like crazy
images of yourself with a we buy this
t-shirt or mug or whatever the hell it
is you buy
again i'm not gonna be profiting from
that um even though i should have done i
probably haven't thought this through um
but i don't want to profit from this
because
i want stargate to be back as much as
all of you guys do because i started
this channel
10 months ago
because i love sidetrack i love sci-fi i
love star trek i love battlestar
galactica but mainly i love stargate
it's always been my favorite show sg1
will always be my favorite show
um
it's just got everything for me it's
just the perfect tv show
and i want it back i want it back just
as much as anybody else that watches me
on here
um i really really i'm sorry 9.97 k
so close so close i if it doesn't happen
tonight it's gonna happen tomorrow but
it'll it'll happen pretty quick but
we'll we'll get to 10k pretty quick
um
todd murray i can't wait for new shows
and i don't want to pay a lot of money
for them i i completely understand that
it is a big reason why amazon that is a
good point todd has made there it's a
big reason why amazon are holding back
on stargate at the moment because
um subscription numbers have slowed
at the moment as far as i can tell subs
um netflix's numbers have actually
dropped
disney's are still increasing reasonably
rapidly but amazons have slowed quite a
lot hbo max has as well
they're expecting a plateau now of
subscriptions of new subscriptions to
the streaming services
um
actually amazon have had quite a large
drop in their um
share price but that isn't as big a deal
as a lot of other youtube channels seem
to make out because actually they had a
massive spike in their share price
during covid because everybody stayed at
home and just ordered amazon and
literally their sales like tripled
overnight
so they had a huge spike and it's just
sort of coming back down towards a more
acceptable level and an understandable
level sort of thing so so there has been
a drop but it's not it's too much to be
expected
um
so amazon answered worried about that
but they are worried about the streaming
service slowing another big problem
they've got is they have really
overspent on lord of the rings
and
again this is a this is a tv production
company that really looks i mean they
all look at numbers and metadata but
these amazon really really do and they
are quite concerned that there's a lot
of negative attention aimed towards lord
of the rings so the fear is that that
might be a flop and if it is a flop
it'll be an insanely expensive one um
this whole thing about a billion dollars
is a little bit exaggerated but it is a
insanely expensive show it's taken up
about an eighth of their actual annual
um
budget for television and movies which
is a huge chunk of money and so
it's made them slow down a little bit in
other areas so let's just go back to
remember you're gonna buy one
where on the day it's not got my logo on
it or anything either guys it's just got
the hashtag and the and the stargate
logo i'd like to say i don't want to do
this to push sidetrack i don't want it
to do this to make money i've done it to
try to push the the plan you know to
push the the idea of doing this um storm
me too everyone get in there buy one i'm
not sure um people can subscribe to only
amazon for stargate project is huge
this is the thing that a lot of
streaming services right now are looking
for they're looking for tv shows that
even if they haven't got massive
popularity and stargate has got massive
pogba hedging it's it's easily
you know potentially it's got the
potential to be as popular as star trek
but
tv shows even like babylon 5 or things
like this cult tv shows that even if
they've got a relatively small following
that would attract new subscribers that
people will subscribe to a streaming
service just for that show
stargate is considered by amazon to be
one of those shows that people will
subscribe to it just for that
um paramount plus is pushing star trek
like crazy because that they know that's
their show that people will subscribe to
it just for star trek
um i've not seen star trek prodigy and
it's driving me crazy paramount plus
doesn't come to the uk excuse me um for
another two weeks
next week actually it's next week um so
you know i'm just i can't wait to watch
that show um and i i do already
subscribe to paramount plus technically
because it's going to be part of my
movie package it's going to be an add-on
but it's free for me because i pay for
that already so i'm very excited about
that um if you're in the uk though and
you get it through sky you have to have
the movie channel to get it for free
otherwise it's quite expensive paraplus
um
but most people because of the living
cost crisis
um are considering now at the moment
they might have two three or four
apparently it's 3.5 or something is the
average in america they're considering
stripping that down to only having two
subscription channels so there is an
expectation of the next 12 months that
there might be a decrease for a lot of
these numbers for streaming services or
at very least like i said a massive
slowdown
um
right i'm an agent boom i got a long to
wait stargate routine so hurry up and
just look we will do our best this is
what we're doing here this is why we're
pushing this so hard
we want to get
this show back on our screens
i will say that though i want to get
this show back on our screens done
properly i don't just want um a piece of
crap show i want a good show i would
like brad wright to be in charge but i
know this is going to be a little
controversial i don't want him to have
free reign i don't like what he did with
sgu i i didn't particularly like
travellers
um and you know i would like i would
like him in charge because i think he
knows stargate inside and out he loves
the project i want somebody the head of
it that loves stargate joseph melosi the
head of the wouldn't bother me either um
but i wouldn't mind some fresh blood now
with writers directors and things like
this i want him to be like a kevin feig
type of thing but i'd like to go in and
maybe be the manager
and to steer the ship but i do want
different stories i do want different
ideas as well i am actually a little bit
concerned seeing and what i've seen
about the pilot script and i have seen
bits i've not shared with you guys
because i don't want to spoil it i wish
i didn't know
um and i'm a little bit worried but i
don't think we'll get to see what brad
wright has written so far i don't think
it's what we'll get to see on the screen
so what i'm being told by people is that
um amazon
um are gonna be reviewing the whole
thing and they're gonna they're gonna go
from top to bottom with it so i'd be
surprised if that's what we've got to
see
um
thomas i'm totally excited about new
shows from amazon but concerned about
the rebooting entire franchise and
disregard everything that happened in
the universe throughout all these years
i don't think they will
but you know we will have to see
um i don't think everything i'm hearing
is that it will not be a hard reboot
that they want to continue the
continuation and if brad wright is
involved it will be a continuation and
they will answer a lot of questions that
we've got over the last 10 years the
tweet objective is 100 000 across the
world which would
put it top of the trending list so let's
let's hope that that
is amazing
it was a solid show and it was getting
better sgu it just wasn't for me i found
it a bit slow and a little boring but i
will admit i've watched it again in the
last 12 months
and it was getting so much better
towards the end um i think it sort of
like suffered
star trek the next generation watch the
first series now it's not very good
other than a couple of episodes
it didn't really get good until they
killed off tashiar and sent geordi
laforge down to engineering then it got
good
um voyager is one of my favorite shows
it was wasn't very good until um that
again halfway through the third series
when 709 came into it the first series
of d space nine isn't very good
um it's a bit boring it took a while to
great sci-fi shows generally do take a
little bit of time to find their feet
and i think that's all it was that's you
to be fair i'm going to be doing a
review of stargate sg1 series 2 um on
saturday at 6 on sunday at 6 00 um with
matt
and
um even though i love the first series
actually there are parts of the second
series that again they're not very good
they're a bit boring and um the finale
of season two is really not very good
um
for me or compared to the rest of the
show anyway still brilliant still
stargate but compared to the rest of the
show it's a bit of a low ebb
um i think that's all it was with sg i
think if sgu had got a third series
we'd have now but by now we'd have had
seven or eight series and it would be
everyone's favorite show because it was
beautifully made it was it had a
brilliant premise it was just a bit slow
i think they i think they took
themselves a little bit too seriously
for me in the first
two series but it was getting better
stargate movie is on amazon prime right
now and
i'm again told
um i think i've shared this already but
i'm again told that the plan is to have
all of the sg series on
uh only amazon prime within the next 18
months um but they can't do it before
then because mgm had signed contracts
with other things like um is it peacock
or the other one i forget um to to show
that just to have the show on there it's
also on sky at the moment it's on sky
catch up
in the uk um so they've got those deals
to run through as soon as those
contracts end it'll be dragged back but
that's to be honest the same for most of
mgm's um products
there are lots of tv shows and things
that mgm produces that they produce for
other channels or it's it's contracted
a lot of those contracts as soon as the
end
those products will be removed back to
amazon but it's not as easy as just
amazon going clicking the things and
going right everything's back now um
there's contracts that mgm agreed to but
long before amazon sale went through
so it will happen but
sgu rocked on the high on that hill
hey
everybody you know i'd say and i would
still say even though stargate wasn't my
favorite it was still better than 99
percent of the tv on shows on tv um i
still watched it and i still loved it
but uh
i just didn't compare to sg1 for me
let's hope it works
um
is there a good sg episode that is
standalone enough to show people to get
them hooked oh that's a good question
bob
you know for me the first series
i forgot what it's called the one where
they end up in antarctica
i thought that was such a clever that
that was probably the first episode
it was the first episode that we saw
the relationship between um
o'neill and carter start to sort of
blossom it and i think it was the one of
the first ones we really saw
what the character o'neill was going to
become you know the wise crap and stuff
we started to see it already but that's
when we really saw it come through
um and for me
out of the first series
that's my favorite episode
children of the gods
is obviously the one that sets it up
that you have to watch because the rest
of it doesn't make sense otherwise um
but it is a bit there's a lot of
information there so as an episode this
is something that all starting episodes
suffer from isn't it they've got so much
information so much story to tell
um it can make the show a bit
difficult sometimes so it's not as
entertaining because there's just so
much going on
and also they have no budget um but
um obviously you'd have to watch those
in the gods double episode but that
episode whatever hell it was called
somebody will say pluto tv thank you bob
um
somebody will tell me what's in a second
in the chat um i would say that episode
for me watch that i i i love that
episode when it came out
um
that old yorkshire geek thank you sir i
subscribed to mgm i was probably i'm
saying okay but hd early seasons would
be nice
um i subscribed to mgm and amazon prime
and then they took stargate off
and or they did sg-1 but you have to pay
for it
and but then somebody actually a lovely
subscriber on here pointed out to me
that you can buy it on but it was on
skype and i got a skype so i was like oh
watch out there's
so yeah
my season two is excellent lou mendetty
yeah so just to recap guys because a lot
more of you are joining while i'm i'm on
on july the 27th is the 25th anniversary
of stargate sg1 airing in the united
states to celebrate but also to give
amazon a bit of a kick up the jacksy
um several other youtubers because
sebastian um who you know we we just
spoke to um
have organized a twitter storm so in the
united states um in los angeles at 1 pm
on the 27th at new york at 4 p.m at 10
o'clock at night in paris and 9 o'clock
here
i will be going live i'm certain
sebastian will be as well and so many
will other youtube channels and we are
going to ask that everybody at the same
time at that time of day
tweet we want stargate
um i have produced a bunch of t-shirts
cups mugs whatever and that i again i
will not be profiting from and they're
available on sidedashtrek.com it's a
you can see it at the bottom there
um i would ask you then to go buy
t-shirt buy a mug do whatever take a
selfie of yourself wearing it and it
hasn't got my logo on it again i'm not
doing this to promote me i'm doing this
to promote the cause and get and add
that to the photo with the hashtag we
want stargate
that will really apparently according to
people that know about twitter that have
asked really does help to push the um
hashtag up the trending list what we
want really ideally is a hundred
thousand tweets but also what we really
really want is to get we want stargate
um trending at the very top of the
twitter top 10. so if we can get that
amazon watch these things they go they
love metadata they cream all over this
and it'll just take us hopefully one
step closer to amazon green light in a
new stargate project because at the
moment it is stuck in review and even
though lots and lots of work was done
for this new show
nothing is happening right now
i was told about um three months ago
that amazon were pushing to actually
green light stargate the new stargate
project by this date of july 27th
but that has cooled significantly as
soon as amazon actually got their hands
on mgm and actually started going
through everything that
was in place
and i think they got their hands on the
books potentially as well but i they
should have had that when they were to
go through the buying process but anyway
once they actually got in charge
they put a pause on everything and they
decided that this wasn't going to happen
anytime soon so please
get on to the
um go go to the go to the website have a
look at the thing buy yourself t-shirt
if you're in the united states it'll
take about a week to come the reason why
i'm doing this video now though is if in
the uk or the rest of the world it'll
take anything up to three weeks to come
so that's the main reason why i'm doing
this video today and i'm telling you to
get on and do it now because this is
like what's six weeks away so if you're
going to get your product and going to
get these t-shirts done and everything
you need to order them as as quickly as
you can
so
sga
um sj is still amazon for me uh i think
it's still on amazon it's just
you have to pay for sg1 i was just
thinking about sg episode where mckay
gets space alzheimer's
oh god i don't remember that episode i
haven't watched stargate atlantis again
for a while it should have been on my
list of things to do um during lockdown
and i watched sg1 i watched firefly
about three times
next on my list i'm gonna start watching
atlantis again
the shrine great episode yes i would i
would completely agree that that is a
brilliant episode
so that is it guys please um
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out share this video
wherever you want but mainly share the
news and share the idea that we are
going to do this and we're going to have
this twitter storm and we are going to
shove our collective
feet right up amazon's backside until
they feel they have no choice but make
the show i don't want them to think that
oh maybe this would be a good idea i
want them to think they'll lynch us if
we don't
and that's that's the message we want to
send we will lynch you if you don't
bring our show back and also if you
don't bring it back properly
because we want a brilliant show we do
not want something half-assed
there is the link psytrek.com
let's just have one last look at the
subscriber count
and we'll see where we're at
we have our four new subscribers we are
13 off so i roam right now i have 9 987
subscribers thank you so much for who
subscribed during the live show it
really does help and
and that is thank you very much sir um
and
you know
we can do this and i will be going live
hopefully tomorrow to tell you that
we've hit 10 000 subscribers
and shelly
who runs my facebook page who has been a
legend going running the facebook page
as well has told me i've gotta be drunk
for that show
so um i might need one or two more of
these
also i'll be playing the game that every
time i say basically i have to have a
drink so
hey
i say basically a lot
so thank you guys for watching i really
really really appreciate it
um
9.98 yeah so close um
i really really appreciate it
get it in your diaries i will be live at
nine o'clock july 27th
to
hammer this home as much as possible we
are going to shout from the rooftops
bring back stargate
thank you very much guys i'm going to
call an evening
again get in the comments share the
video share the idea let's get out there
let's get this done
all right guys thank you so so much
don't forget to go and buy your t-shirt
or mug or whatever you want okay thanks
guys bye-bye
you